a big news out of North Korea BBC and
CNN are reporting that North Korea has
fired a ballistic missile from a
submarine off of its east coast the K
and 11 missile was launched from the
waters near sin po and flew about 500
kilometers before falling into the sea
of japan according to a US official
japan's prime minister said that it fell
inside their air defense identification
zone and thus they are calling this a
reckless act this seems to happen often
Louis when South Korea and the US are
starting their military drills these are
totally routine South Korea and the u.s.
doing these drills together it is also
completely routine that North Korea gets
very very angry when South Korea and the
United States do this uh this is
something we have seen before often
times this ends with more food aid going
to North Korea as well and we've talked
about that louis were a lot of time
these sort of belligerent seeming
escalations are actually calls for
someone to offer them more food even
though they deny there's any famine
problem whatsoever all of a sudden they
scale back down when they get more food
supplies which is brilliant really
because it seems to work every time and
uh unfortunately that food pretty much
just goes to a summit will go to
military members most it will just go to
the higher-ups in the elites in
Pyongyang and the the status quo will
remain some people laugh this off and
they say I just North Korea it's always
the same thing they never hit anything
it doesn't matter although I I think
that that's maybe a little a little too
presumptuous to just laugh this off as
there will never be anything here this
was the most successful test yet of the
submarine launched ballistic missiles
SLBMs and these are particularly
concerning because if you combine the
mobility of the submarine and how you
can prepare for launch undetected
compared to a launch that would come
from from the surface of the earth uh
this could potentially do damage and
conceptually although they they've as we
know not done it some of these uh
missiles that North Korea
has could reach parts of the US or
allied territory so I'm not of the
mindset Louis that we should be
completely laughing this off I think at
some point what are sometimes written
off is just intimidation tactics will
not be just that may be deliberately or
or honestly maybe by mistake but I don't
think we should just ignore this know it
we shouldn't ignore it say it really
wouldn't take much for missiles to start
being exchanged between north and south
korea um and the idea that they can
launch these from anywhere uh this is a
very desperate leader right in a very
desperate country not something uh to
just uh ignore no doubt about it and
will continue following it I've talked
about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at join
zipcar dot-com slash david